Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in surah
chapter number 73
the final verse verse number 20.
It's a verse which contains in it
an element or a method of legislation
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala refers to
elsewhere in the Quran as an
what is an
is
that a verse or a ruling
may be changed.
It could be
made more strict. It could be made
less strict. It could go from something
that is waj to later being mustab. It
could go from something that isab to
later becoming waj. And it can do the
same thing with respect to prohibitions.
It could be something that is
discouraged and then later made
prohibited. It could be something that
is at first prohibited and then later
made discouraged etc. There are many
there are many instances of a ness or in
English we would say abrogation
throughout the Quran and throughout
the sunnah.
Now this issue of
is something which all of the scholars
of Islam
it is found in the Quran. It's evidence
for a is in the Quran in the sunnah and
also the consensus
of the scholars and the ummah of Islam
in general that this is something which
is found in the legislation of the Quran
in the legislation of the sunnah that
something would be
a law would be set
and then later changed. by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is something
which only occurs in laws and it does
not occur in
doesn't occur in
information. So for instance, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is not going to
abregate one of his names, one of his
attributes that that that is no longer
one of his names, no longer one of his
attributes or something happened and
then later it said that it didn't happen
something that. Obviously that is
not the realm of a ness. A ness is a
legislative device that is used by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in order to
incrementally
introduce change
in the society as a whole or the
individuals
etc.
And this is something which all of the
Muslim agree is found in the Quran, is
found in the Sunnah. And why not
being that the Quran
abregated?
What book? What book did the Quran
abrogate?
Huh?
Correct. Every book has been abrogated
by the Quran
and abrogation happens in the Quran. It
happens in the sunnah and this is not a
reflection of a deficiency in
legislation.
there were innovative groups that
came to be in Islam
that
started to from their claim from an
intellectual or from a rational sense
deny the existence of a in the Quran and
Sunnah.
And this is something that is an
innovation that later cropped up in
roughly
the 3rd century after hijra. So the
Muslim never differed on this issue.
Roughly 250
years later the jahya were introduced.
The mortzilla were introduced and one of
their innovations was that abrogation is
something that cannot happen. It cannot
be. However, this is rejected. This is
rejected by the clear verses of the
Quran, the clear verse narrations of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam and the
consensus the of all of the Muslim.
[Silence]
Subhanahua
youth bit.
What you bit
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
Bakar
about in the Quran. He tells us in Bakar
that no verse do we abregate nor make
you to forget except that we will
replace it with one equal or better.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala it is his book
and that is to his discretion.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala later says in
he says Allah erases whatever he chooses
and he affirms whatever he chooses of
the book subhanahu wa ta'ala of laws of
prohibitions of obligations
etc
and so this is something which is found
in the Quran there are verses which
abregate other verses
Now this doesn't happen
always in the same way. Sometimes
only a portion of a verse is abregated
or only a portion of a ruling is
abregated
such as the verse that we have here
verse number 20 when we look at the very
beginning of the chapter Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says
Stand for prayer at night.
Stand for prayer all the night except
for a portion. This is an obligation.
This wording here, this wording and this
diction, this articulates obligation. It
is binding. And we discussed how this
was obligatory at the very beginning of
Islam and then was later made must later
made highly encouraged when the five
daily prayers were obligated in the way
that we have them today.
Now in this verse, so that's at the very
first the second verse of the chapter.
Then we fast forward to this verse which
we know
was revealed way later in the days of
Mecca
M was revealed and it said that it
is the third chapter to be revealed in
that consecutive order but the 20th
verse was not revealed at the same time.
The 20th verse was revealed way later.
How do we know that? Well, we know that
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions jihad
and the
issue of jihad only came up in the
way later years of the Meccan era and
was later made permissible and then made
preferable and then made obligatory in
the days of Medina.
So this is this verse when we look at
the subject matter, we look at what it
talks about, what it discusses, we can
kind of see that this verse was revealed
in the way later days of Mecca. And as a
matter of fact, we know that this
issue of jihad started to be started
to be
kind of
articulated in so many words. We started
to kind of see that jihad will
eventually become something in the
future. Glimpses of it and glimmers of
it come up throughout the verses and
chapters that were revealed in Mecca as
kind of a as kind of a
as kind of a prelude to jihad that this
will become something. But this only
came up in the later years of Mecca.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala here says in
this verse
he says says,
[Silence]
he says, "Indeed your Lord
knows knows very well that you stand for
prayer
in the night
a little less than 23 of the night or
a little less than half of the night or
a third of the night. You along with a
band of those who are with you meaning
of his companions
meaning a group from those who are with
you. Meaning that it wasn't all of the
Muslim that were standing for.
It was only some that were making salah
in others were not. And this is why the
strongest opinion of the scholars is
that standing for prayer at night to it
was only made obligatory upon the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam at the
beginning and
highly encouraged for the rest of the
Muslim. that was later then abregated
and it remained either obligatory or
highly encouraged for the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
as well. And so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says, "And Allah is the one who
decides and he is the one who sets the
parameters. He sets the lengths. He is
the one who causes the length of the
days and nights to vary, to increase or
decrease. He is the one who decrees
that." He says
he knows that you will not be able to
maintain this kind of prayer all year
round all of the time
for all of the future. Things will
happen. People will get sick. People
will forget. People will get busy.
People will travel. circumstances
change, right? And so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala then says
and so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has has
made then thus things easier for you.
So now we are going from obligation to
what to
something which is preferable which is a
type of abrogation.
Notice how it was done.
You'll see this pattern
throughout the legislation of Islam with
respect to
things that are a new discipline
that we are supposed to be learning.
It starts out really intense and then it
eases up. And this is how we learn
discipline. This is how we change
habits.
you notice for instance
with respect to many legislations
of Islam, it starts out very intense and
then when everybody
learns that discipline
of that which is intense, then it takes
it back a notch and it makes it less
intense. Why? Because that discipline
will now remain. Same thing with wudoo.
Wudoo at the very beginning
was obligatory for every prayer
whether you broke your wudoo or not a
person would make wudoo every time they
wish to pray.
And so now this became a part of what a
part of people's discipline because a
new discipline is being learned. Then
when it became part of everyone's
discipline, everyone is doing it.
Everyone is fulfilling it. They are used
to that which is more difficult. Now it
can ease up a little bit and it becomes
now it is
it is preferred that a pe person make
woo every time they go to pray but it's
not obligatory.
The same thing happened with
with
the same thing with fasting.
In fasting
when Ramadan was first obl obligated,
the way that it worked is that a person
if they were to
break their fast
and they were to fall asleep
and they had not eaten yet, they were
not permitted to eat until the next
morning.
So they had to fast all through the
night.
Why is that? Why is that ruling so
strict?
Because a new discipline now is being
introduced. Fasting this is something
fasting for an entire month. Fasting one
day, people can do that. Fasting an
entire month, that's a new thing. So
Allah began with the very strict and
then over time it became permissible to
eat any time during the hours of the
night. As long as it's night time, eat
anytime you want. So it eased up. The
same thing with respect to
salah. We've mentioned salah. We've
mentioned fasting. And you'll find this
all through the Quran. And it moves
differently when it comes to that which
is prohibited.
In prohibiting something, it doesn't
start ex extreme and then become easier.
It usually starts easy and slowly
intensifies.
You see that pattern with the
prohibition of alcohol, with the
prohibition of ribba, with the
prohibition of gambling, with the
prohibit, it started out what
slowly intensifies over time.
So as these new habits are being built,
these old habits are being phased out.
And so when it comes to new obligations,
new disciplines, we'll see a pattern
where it starts really intense and then
gets easier. And when it comes to
prohibitions, it's the opposite. It
starts out really easy and slowly what
intensifies. And this is the same
pattern that we see here in this verse.
Foreham.